what's up guys bang bang this video is
brought to you by prime xbt
they are a crypto trading platform that
has an excellent award-winning
environment for margin trading if you
want to go check out
their crypto trading be sure to check
out their copy trading module which
allows you to replicate the trades of
the most successful traders with a
proven track record
if you're interested you can register
with the link below and you can get a
50 deposit bonus go check them out at
prime
xbt and let's get into this interview
[Music]
all right guys bang bang i've got a very
special guest today i've got simon here
with me thank you so much for doing this
sir
thank you bob so very excited to be here
for sure let's just jump right into your
background you've got a very unique
perspective on the world so kind of
help everyone understand where did you
grow up and then kind of what have you
done over the years before you started
value
of course um so i guess they can start
by saying that
i am a migrant um
right now um i live in colombia but
i was born in venezuela and due to the
economic
collapse on hyperinflation in the
country
i decided to migrate from a very early
age
you know everything that venezuelans
families and my family built
was lost and so for me the
solution of crypto and what it brings to
the table is something personal
i migrated to spain to play soccer from
a very early age
i played for real madrid um and then i
did industrial design in the united
states
so that was my second migration and in
2014
i fell down the crypto rabbit hole um
essentially right after i graduated from
from
from college um i found about ethereum
then quickly i found about crypto and
then i started figuring out what
what i wanted to do with
cryptocurrencies
in latin america especially in venezuela
because of the
potential impact to solve hyperinflation
and solve these problems
and now i'm living in colombia so that's
a little bit about me
in general i love building companies and
getting a lot of people together
to solve large problems so i think
crypto falls into that category talk a
little bit just about as a kid
uh the hyperinflation and kind of the
collapse of the the venezuelan
society and government uh kind of what
was your experience there and any
specific stories that kind of stand out
to you to really highlight this for
folks
sure um i guess i can you know tell you
a little bit of
an analogy um you know when we were
growing up
uh the government multiple times because
of this hyperinflation
um which means everything was just
getting more expensive you know you guys
in the united states
are experiencing a little bit of that
right now
it's really hard to know what's the
inflation rate because the federal
reserve potentially
won't release the real numbers but
everybody tells me that
life is just getting way more expensive
in the u.s uh so you're if you're
holding your currency in the local fiat
in the local
uh currency issued by the government
then you're just becoming poorer right a
car cash poor
um in venezuela that is um that that
became
uh hyperinflation which means that money
loses value at a ridiculous rate
in january for example uh we had a
thousand percent
uh january of 2021 uh we had a thousand
percent hyperinflation
um and if we look at it in past 20 years
we've just had um ridiculous numbers of
uh of inflation which means
you know going back to the analogy um
when we were growing up
um the the government used to take out
zeros
from the currency because the the number
the numbers were just
getting super large um so today
a dollar a an american dollar is worth
like
uh 1 billion 1 million bolivars
but if we add the zeros that the
government has taken out
one us dollar is about 1 trillion over
over 1 trillion bolivars so as you can
imagine
um cash bills couldn't keep up with this
uh with this hyperinflation and now cash
is worthless
i could literally like burn you know
i could take a full paper wall of
bills of venezuela and burn them and and
i wouldn't care
uh and cash is exactly worth it so
a lot of people in the crypto space may
have seen that people in venezuela use
the cash bills to build uh or to do art
or to do
uh like purses uh because the purse that
you make out of these bills is more
uh has more value than the actual money
um
so those are just some of the examples
and analogies i can bring to the table
but you know growing up in a country
like that
where 50 inflation happens in a day
where you go in the morning and to buy
milk and then
you go out in the afternoon it and the
milk is twice as expensive
you really become i guess financially
savvy
on how to survive right how to survive
in a country like that
and everybody in venezuela became
somewhat financially savvy
um you know from people that are cash
poor to rich people
and that just generated as well my
huge migration i miss management of the
country that is not only monetary
is uh also from an executive perspective
there's no food
there were food shortages back in the
day mismanagement of the
energy systems so bad internet and
people started migrating
and businesses started to to go broke um
and um and and now we have we we came
from being
potentially one of the richest countries
um in resources in
the world and one of the richest
countries in latin america
to the poorest country in latin america
even poorer than
haiti so really big uh
drastic change talk a little bit about
before
uh bitcoin and cryptocurrencies what
were people doing
when you became financially savvy what
were they doing to protect
uh their wealth or their purchasing
power
so people were basically buying uh uh
stuff buying assets that were trying to
not hold their money
in the venezuelan bolivar so um you know
back in the day when this was happening
people would
you know turn into buying real estate or
buying
um or just spending it in like
restaurants or
storing a bunch of food um and uh
and then trading these foods so uh even
barter
became something uh you know not a super
large scale but
people started to barter uh you know um
things
and so uh communities got together
uh to buy for example uh water
for the buildings and then you would buy
one of those large
trucks of water uh once like like to
spend
all the boulevards as much as you can
and just hold your money water i guess
um and so that became the norm just
putting
your money in um in in things that were
um less liquid i guess um
and uh and and food and things like that
and some
some of the other people were starting
to buy things like gold
and then when bitcoin became something
um when bitcoin became
like more well-known especially with
local bitcoins
which is a peer-to-peer uh trading
market
um college students started to
to getting like to understand it and and
grasp
the concept of storing your money in
bitcoin um
i think that was in 2017
20 even before the 2017 bubble um
and uh and then these students got so
excited and these young people got so
excited that they started teaching their
grandmothers and
their grandfathers and their parents
about it some of them got it
some of them didn't but the whole
country
knew about it at least understood that
there was this alternative
digital currency internet money
uh medical internet money that people
could use to hold their value
instead of the local currency um and you
know that's from a very basic
perspective from a
from a more financially savvy
perspective you know the amount of
financial engineering and financial
loopholes that
you know richer uh more educated people
could find what's ridiculous
some people for example started asking
credits from the banks in the local
currency
and buying an apartment in manhattan and
then
paying that credit in venezuela and
bolivars over you know
10 years 15 years and they would buy an
apartment in manhattan for like
the uh equivalent of you know a thousand
dollars or less
and so you know that's you know that's
definitely corruption in some way
but i i have heard of people that did
this and that's just an
uh kind of like um something that i
wanted to share
as you can imagine if that's one thing
that you can do
in hyperinflationary economy there's so
many things you can do
to hack the system and to you know get
away with that
absolutely and so let's talk a little
bit about what you're building with
value
uh i'm an investor in the business i
think that this is a really really
unique
uh type of solution and one that's
gaining market adoption but just
talk through kind of the impetus uh for
the idea
uh and kind of what you guys have built
so far
yeah so one of the things i i would like
to start with the problem right
um and um the
while we are potentially um
solving hyperinflation and rampant
inflation um and even
we can potentially save venezuela
so if value um
if everybody in latin america puts their
money into value
we we we think that we have virtually
solved the largest problem in the region
and value is essentially as sim as a
simple dollar account for latin
americans
that allow people to save money in
dollars
in crypto dollars and send remittances
or international money transfers
between themselves for free at no cost
and and immediately um so
it's just an app a mobile app and where
people can connect
their bank or pay with cash in more than
30 000
locations in colombia people in
venezuela can connect their banks
because venezuela because of the
hyperinflation
is fully banked uh it's a it's a it's a
country that
we're more even more than the united
states
people have a bank account um so
if you're in venezuela if you're in
colombia you can turn your
call your fiat your venezuelan bolivars
or your colombian pesos
into crypto dollars you can then send
them for free and immediately between
anybody between these two countries
and people can also you know use it for
uh saving
and protecting their assets from the
hyperinflationary
economy in venezuela and from the the
appreciative economy
in colombia which is while it's not
hyperinflation in colombia over the
past for example five years the currency
has lost
about 30 percent of its value or more
against the dollar
so this is a solution that well the
initial focus is for venezuelans
both that are still living in venezuela
and migrants
across the world um this is a solution
that
may help any other population in latin
america
and and and help them have more
financial prosperity
whether you're a farmer in the middle of
venezuela or a banker in the city you
can access dollars and make money
every day because your money in value
dollars is appreciating against local
fields
talk a little bit just how you're
technically doing this
yeah so we use a combination of crypto
uh and and i would like to say that
we are extremely pragmatic um i love
crypto i love blockchain i love the
potential that it has
um you know the transparency the
permissionless uh
multi-signature accounts that people can
actually you know hold their keys and be
their own bank
uh in a way but the reality is that
in latin america specifically in
emerging markets um
people do not have the tools uh the
education
and to understand this so they are
really demanding for very simple stuff
like
is it safe is it uh and is it like you
know is my money gonna be in dollars
essentially because you know the dollar
is the
is the current uh um
kind of like uh store of value that you
know and most people in the world uh
think is the best uh still bitcoin
hasn't still got
gotten there but you know over time our
strategy is that
initially we're gonna give people what
they want um
but very simple products built on top of
crypto but over time as we increase our
user base we're going to give them
bitcoin and we're going to give them
multi-signature non-console accounts
but that is not the right time just yet
um
so the way we do this i wanted to give
that initial kind of like
um explanation because
um we have an iou initially i nailed
you because it allows us to do these
free immediate transfers
which is one of the ways we um we
essentially
uh acquire users and promote that you
know we're
effectively killing the remittance
business by helping people transfer
money between countries at no cost
and potentially acquiring all these
western union users
so it's an iou which means that it's
essentially a centralized
accounting system that is mirroring uh
crypto that we have custodied in uh
places like
circle um and and other places
and um and so we back the value dollar
which is an iou
with one to one with other stable coins
um
and the way we on ramp is through
bitcoin so initially when we started it
it was all bitcoin uh we were offering
fiat to fiat remittances and we were
buying bitcoin in the country
uh of the sender and then we were
selling the bitcoin in the country of
the recipient to get the fiat
and send it to their bank account in
venezuela like i mentioned
everybody has a bank account so um so
when you
do the off ramp in venezuela you pay
directly to the banks
and we do that in a peer-to-peer fashion
in a
in like a decentralized fashion of sorts
uh by doing it in peer-to-peer uh
exchanges
and so we never touch the venezuelan
banking system
uh because we don't wanna do that
because venezuela is a dictatorship
um and so we effectively can hack the
system through these peer-to-peer
systems
uh exchanges and and that's how we offer
them
um and it was all going through bitcoin
so we our
main goal at the time was really how how
do we manage our treasury and how do we
protect
uh ourselves from the risk of having
bitcoin for this
period of time so we started playing
around with hedging and futures
and then we found that we could
effectively um
create um a synthetic exposure to the
dollar
through uh doing um bitcoin
uh futures trading and derivatives
trading so
um at that time we said all right let's
offer dollars to people
or let's offer a synthetic dollar that
is backed in bitcoin uh derivatives
um and uh we recently changed that
because we were
holding that in bitmex and with what
with everything that happened recently
you know it definitely showed that this
is a risk in the end it's not that we're
actually
custodian these assets ourselves this
money is locked
in these third-party exchanges so we
finally made the decision to back the
value dollar with stable coins
um and um and this is all i can say
right now but
we are working ourselves in building our
own uh
blockchain and our own token um because
one of the most important things is to
over time make this censorship resistant
um it's really really important that
this is censorship resistant
and the one of the best ways to do this
is by making the value dollar not an iu
actually creating a token um and then
building in our own blockchain and over
time
giving people with really good ux
a way for them to hold their keys talk a
little bit about the
market adoption so far right so where
are you seeing people using this
uh how is it going in terms of uh
the the amount um of transactions or
just like any data that you could share
around you know do people want this and
are they using it
yeah so you know we we launched 15
months ago
in october of 2019
and um in 2020 we moved 10x uh we went
from 3000 multi-active users to 30 000
multi-active users
um and a lot of it was organic growth uh
the reality is that
this is a matter of life or death for
some people right like accessing
dollars uh or stronger currencies in in
in a place that is hyperinflationary or
even
in colombia uh in general in latin
america is really hard to access dollars
um and specifically in venezuela it's
it's a life or death
thing so um so being such an
intense need what we're offering for
people
um it's it's really really important and
uh right now we have um since we
launched about 80 000 people have used
our products
and about 30 000 monthly active retained
um where we have moved about nine
million dollars from colombia to
venezuela
and uh we're talking about like
low-income migrants right so
um super super important uh effectively
have
potentially helped about 200 000 or even
more households in venezuela
um access the stability of the dollar
and over time uh what we're going to
continue to do
is um like i mentioned make it more uh
censorship resistant
making it more decentralized educating
people
on the advantages of these technologies
and working with merchants so that the
product
you know is used for payments
essentially closing the
the pipe i would say uh today most
people have to cash out into the bolivar
into the local fiat
to pay because crypto most mostly
anywhere in the world is
still not used as a medium of payment uh
but in venezuela
given the the situation of
hyperinflation everybody's looking for
something else
uh to to accept payments uh you know the
trust
barrier for crypto is is
way lower than anywhere in the world i
would say so
um so we're going to be launching your
payments soon
and we're going to be focusing on
opening these uh merchant
accounts so that conversations can
accept
payments in value dollars and that's
definitely going to be an important
moment for us to you know as a company
to create more impact
to onboard more users uh we recently
enabled
caches in venezuela so which i believe
is
the most important thing with
accomplishments as a company right uh
you know effectively helping people turn
their hyperinflationary currency
into the dollar in venezuela back in the
day
the only way they could access this was
through their family members in colombia
sending them remittances
but now they can actually you know cash
in in venezuela
um and um and so
that's effectively um what we have done
so far
how many people are using it and um
and what's i guess what's also
interesting is that through the
venezuelan
use case which is this diaspora that has
left the country to colombia peru
virtually every country latin america
the united states spain
um we can expand to all these other
places because all these other regions
build the on and offerings for them for
the venezuelan migrants
and then once we have designed an
offerings then this is a
product that also works for local
populations of colombia
brazil peru uh mexico so the venezuelan
use case is really
really strategic strategic
and so when you think through you know
kind of just
uh bitcoin cryptocurrencies value
dollars
uh in south and central america is this
something where you think that
um you know we're gonna eventually
replace the
legacy fiat currencies uh with these new
digital
um currencies or will there still be
coexistence it'll just be like the fiat
ones are really bad at
doing what they're supposed to do uh the
digital ones are better
but the digital ones don't necessarily
knock off or kill the
the fiat currencies yeah i think
i think time will tell um you know
our bet and the reason why we started
value down here in
latin america and emerging markets it's
hard because
latin americans love the us dollar and
stable coins
you know have this you know mirror um
value to the dollar
um and it's a good kind of like gateway
drug into cryptocurrencies i guess for
most people
uh you know these are stable points and
over time hopefully you know things like
bitcoin take over as well
but um but i do think that
while time will tell latin american
emerging economies are the places that
are
more prone to the uh for this
for the system to be replaced by crypto
um
because the the
uh the chaos uh in the and the impact
of uh uh financial prices
down here uh in the emerging markets in
general
it's it's really really really large you
know from a macro
macro economic perspective um not only
we have uh hyperinflationary currencies
in economies but we also have like i was
mentioning um
the depreciated uh
economies which means that you know we
import a lot of things
uh we only produce primary commodities
like petroleum
which is now less in need from uh first
world countries
uh we haven't made the investments in
education and all these things so
over time a crisis down here will just
prove the system
to be uh way more ineffective um
and um and uh specifically in countries
like venezuela like i was mentioning
uh if i i truly believe that venezuela
can become the first crypto economy in
the world
and um if the political uh um
um if the government changes and uh
and the power changes hand in venezuela
which you know time will tell
i can tell you that the good guys that
we know them
are pro crypto are pro building because
they
we we're actually seeing the effects of
actually air dropping money to uh
venezuelan uh teachers and medical
workers
through crypto um and you know this is
being led by the opposition by the good
guys
so they they already seen they already
actually seen this
this potential that he has uh of
overcoming um centralized authoritarian
uh regimes so um so i truly believe
uh in 10 years we'll potentially you
know have the first crypto economy
um hopefully down here in south america
and um
and and hopefully that spreads
throughout the region
talk a little bit about the education of
the population so the technology
obviously we've talked a little bit
about in terms of how that's evolving
and how
far along it is what about the actual
knowledge of the people to know that
this is a better system
that uh there's very simple ways to use
it
and to basically just get them up to
speed so that they feel comfortable
using the technology uh what do you see
happening there and are there any areas
that
would surprise people yeah
i think you know education is the most
important thing
um for sure um the
uh and it doesn't have to be a
boring education it doesn't have to be
uh
you know long long information
uh and papers about you know how money
works and how crypto is better
i think education starts by building
great products
uh and then teaching people the features
that these products
are uh giving them and so it has to be
embedded
in the product itself it's not that you
have to teach people how to use it
because then you have a
shitty product you have to really build
great great products but
but you can also take advantage of these
opportunities to
quickly hint and show them why this is
better uh and this
is a really really important challenge
in a big choice at all
um and so and i think
uh that is uh you know apart from a few
other things like on and off ramps
theater on upgrams the the key for for
crypto mainstream adoption
is education for sure
what do you think is the biggest risk uh
or the thing that you're most worried
about when it comes to adoption
in south and central america
you know um
we continue to have i guess this is not
only for
central america and south america we
continue to have uh democracies right
um and i think the democracy has uh
democracy has failed
as a political system um it's a
it's a system where um you know you have
parties
where people are divided uh where
um you know you you make a career
of being a politician instead of
actually but you know
everybody should be a politician to work
for the people so this the democracy
system
um and you know i can't keep on talking
about this but i'm not gonna get into
that rabbit hole but
the democracy has failed in my opinion
and so that means
that power is so centralized and we are
so dependent
on for crypto to be uh successful on
politicians that um that worries me
across the across the board on in even
in the united states
um and so um
uh i think that
unless we move really fast like
really fast as an industry unless we
really
are stay true to our values because you
know we're seeing more and more
companies
enter the space more and more people
enter the space
recently and um but most of these people
haven't been
in the space since the early days and
they haven't been here because of
why this why crypto is better um
there might be a lot of people just
trying to make a buck or make money by
building a company in the space
but um and this might be successful
companies so
that's when when when it really becomes
scary for me
i really think that you know the good
guys in the industry the people that are
working on the centralized
systems fully decentralized on
non-custodial accounts
on privacy these are the people have to
win
um and um you know asset value we're you
know
learning every day and we're making our
best to you know
pragmatically um first
acquire the users and then help them
transition into these new more
uh sovereign systems and these new
better systems um
so i think those two those those are two
things that worry me most uh the
political
uh dependency and the and uh
and which are the companies that are
going to actually uh
lead the way in space got it
and so when you think through uh kind of
where this is all going right
let's zoom out and look forward ten
years how do you view
uh value ten years from now and kind of
what would be the milestone of success
uh or kind of the the
maybe not finish line but kind of the
thing that you're aiming at
uh what does that world look like a
decade out
so contrary to what most people think uh
i think the crypto space has a really
unique uh characteristic where this is
not going to be a winner takes all
type of industry the reason is exactly
because what i just mentioned
the the regulatory hurdles um
this regulatory uh and compliance
hurdles
will mean that there will be silos of
companies that will target
specific regions and so for value
i think what the most important thing
for us is is dominating latin america
and helping latin americans um
transition
into into crypto um and into dollar
accounts and then into bitcoin
so you know ten years from now we hope
to be uh dominating latin america from
that perspective
um and then connecting latin america to
the rest of the world because
we are saying if we imagine a world
where we have this silos
um of companies that are in different
regions and they're all working
in blockchain and in crypto the uh
interoperability uh you know i'm sure
in 10 years we'll have interoperability
with cryptos and blockchains
um it will be just a more global uh you
know
uh financial system um so
that's where i see value in 10 years
very very very much focused in latin
america and connecting latin america to
the rest
of the world on that path what are the
uh data points not necessarily the
numbers you're trying to achieve but
just what are the data points you think
will be most important
uh for you inside of value or for folks
who are interested in the crypto markets
in general to pay attention to is it
number of users transactions uh exchange
traded volume
price what do you think is the most
important things there
i i do believe is uh two things uh
assets under management uh for the
companies that are uh in the space
uh so you know the amount of of crypto i
would say crypto under management
um which means effectively that people
are holding their crypto
and that if they're paying with crypto
they're paying to other people but
the crypto is not leaving back into fiat
so if we see that growing
uh that trend growing over time that's
gonna mean uh
you know the crypto is actually uh
overthrowing uh fiat
and that is being successful um secondly
which
goes hand in hand with that is the
cash-ins uh
so on-ramps effectively you know um the
amount of people turning
uh their creep their fiat into crypto
through cachings
um and i think those two things are
definitely gonna be uh
really really important of course you
know we're talking about
like any company uh uh um
market share uh in terms of users we
have about um
i believe about uh 600 million uh people
in latin america
um and uh you know half of them are
unbanked
yet which is really als an awesome
opportunity for crypto
um and um and so
you know the fact that anybody with an
internet connection and a smartphone can
can have their own uh uh money and and
don't go through the banking system
uh i think that's a really really
important
um kind of development for for the
region
and um i would say those those are the
three things
amount of users uh you know compared to
the market
um uh cash ins and uh crypto under
management
yeah those are three definitely great
ones uh before we wrap up i always ask
everyone the same two questions
uh the first question is what is the
most important book that you've ever
read
the most important book oh man
you know i have to say that um i became
a less of a fan of business books over
time
i uh you know following very much what
nabal says
uh i figured that a lot of these
concepts i can learn them from
youtube videos and things like that
however i can tell you the one book that
i
really enjoyed and this is not related
to crypt
it's actually related to company
building is the hard thing about hard
things by ben horowitz
uh if you're a ceo or a founder even in
the early days
a lot of these advice is for when you
are actually starting to scale up
but even from the early days if you read
that um
it's i think it's super super valuable
um
and of course uh for people that are
interested in crypto
read the bitcoin white paper i think
that's a great piece of advice
uh the second is a question brought by
our friends at eight sleep they've got a
thermo
regulation uh bed so it makes it very
cold for you
to go to sleep get deeper sleep i sleep
with it every night i love it
uh what is your sleep schedule i used to
be one of these people who didn't sleep
at all
and now uh now i feel like a little baby
i'm a convert to the sleep religion if
you will
uh what what is uh your sleep schedule
every day
i sleep um like clockwork at 11 p.m
sometimes i at 11 30 pm then i wake up
at 6 00
6 a.m 6 30 so i usually sleep uh seven
hours it works for me
so far over time and it seems that the
older i get
i need less sleep um i i wake up you
know uh
rested uh after less time um
i do value sleep a lot and i value uh
you know
habits for me my my schedule is
extremely
uh strict um so that's a little bit of
my
asleep story i love it uh
in terms of the uh the third question uh
it's a little bit more fun
aliens are you a believer or a
non-believer
i'm a believer i'm a believer i don't
know if we have
uh you know have any contact with aliens
but from
you know math uh just from math
perspective and what we know so far
from the universe it's very unlikely
that there's no
uh aliens so yeah
i i think they're out there man we'll
see i think they're there somewhere but
i don't know if we're ever gonna run
into them that's for sure
you could ask me one question to wrap up
what's the one question you have for me
man how the hell do you create so much
content
listen i'm learning right and this is uh
this is the third podcast that i'm
recording today
and uh i uh basically have sat here for
a number of hours uh and i'm just
learning i get asked all these questions
uh and it's pretty crazy like the way i
look at it is i get to sit here uh
two days a week so wednesdays and
thursdays normally uh in the afternoon
and i just have people come on and they
tell me everything that they know
right they tell me all the secrets they
tell me all of their insights
and so that helps from a podcast
standpoint and then the rest of this
stuff
is i just kind of live my life on the
internet right it's uh when i think of
something i say
i got something to respond to somebody i
respond that just kind of
everything i do i i have no uh no things
that aren't on the internet
and uh what it does is it allows me to
kind of put out like the uh
um you know the the bat light if you
will right remember when batman would
put it up in the
in the sky it's the same thing uh people
know what i'm
you know into what i want to learn about
the type of people i'm looking for
and so i just use the internet to my
advantage and part of that is
creating content so i'm having a blast
and i keep doing it
at some point i'll probably get tired
and then one day i'll just wake up and
just
i'll disappear off the internet
yeah i asked that because i'm i'm i'm
starting to
focus on creating more content for
spanish-speaking people
and you know running running a company
that's that's not my priority so i'm
trying to figure out how
do i optimize for that uh you're
tweeting in spanish more right
i'm i'm gonna be starting i'm starting
to do that and i'm gonna continue to do
that more and more
um both in spanish and english but
definitely with the focus
of you know helping spread the uh
education uh
and educate people in latin america
about uh money
why money why crypto is money the
problems with the fiat
infrastructure and all that so making it
by size
you know abstracting complexity it's
really really important
yeah i mean look it's uh it's obviously
very clear that
uh if you're able to uh take what is uh
you know kind of all the ideas and
analysis that's in english and get it
into spanish
um and really help people in kind of the
part of the world that
literally they just can't understand it
right just in a different language
um it's uh if you can kind of bridge
that device it goes both ways right
people in the united states
they don't know what's going on in south
and central america because they'll
speak the language
uh and so i think that it by bridging
that divide uh would be fantastic
so well please please please keep doing
that yeah
i i will i will where can we send people
to find you on the internet or find
uh value so uh you can find me at
twitter
uh at simon value uh values uh
v a l i u like volume
like drug but without m
so simon value um in twitter i don't
have ins
instagram yet um or facebook so and you
can follow value
uh as well at value co uh or value com
for
spanish-speaking people and twitter um
and if i you know you have
spanish-speaking people
listeners that are in colombia or
venezuela want to try our product
you know just go to the app store or
google play and type value and you will
find it right away
amazing listen thank you so much for for
coming on and talking about this i know
you're very busy
and we got a company to build so keep uh
keep going i think that it's a
no-brainer in terms of providing the
solution to people in south
central america so i'm excited to uh to
be part of the journey
and uh just really proud of all the work
you've done so we'll have to do it again
in the future
awesome thank you bob take care man